hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I am so excited before we get
started this video is for charity what
is inside this Xbox is something that I
created with my own two hands I'm so
hyped to see what it looks like
Xbox came to me and asked if I wanted to
design an Xbox for charity and I said
hey we can design it for you whatever of
course I was like no I want to do this
what did you this myself
I've a background in graphic design so
if you guys don't know that I do I used
to basically that was my job I was a
raft designer in addition to doing video
production and making websites and all
the things that come along with that but
one of the most satisfying things as a
designer or a creator is being able to
design something and then see it put
into production so inside here is the
Xbox that I made with my own to
designing fingers I went to illustrator
I found myself some sort of generic came
a background traced it and then placed
each piece of camo on this xbox where
you'll see it so I guess if it looks
good then it's my fault if it looks bad
it's hosted my fault but I think it's
gonna look good I'll put a link in the
description if you guys want more
information on the charity there's a
bunch of other Xboxes too so if this
isn't quite your style which I don't
know why it wouldn't because I know it's
gonna be fantastic I think the rock has
one post Malone has one so go check
those out donate if you can I know that
probably the donations may end up
getting a little bit higher than
something that you would ever want to
pay for an Xbox if that's the case and
you're a company it's your company to
sponsor and get this Xbox because I
would love to raise as much money as
possible and a side note if it is a
company that ends up winning this and
just to cover myself here if it is a
company that I like something that I
promote and it's nothing vulgar or
inappropriate I will make a separate
video talking about this whole charity
and maybe doing some gameplay and giving
them a shout-out with that being said
I'm excited to get started and unbox
this this is stressful it's seeing what
you've done and made oh I just spotted
it I spotted it
here it is Oh get everything out I also
designed the control or two to match so
let's look at the controller first oh my
goodness can you even believe how
freaking cool this is
I put missile IG there I basically
designed an Xbox that I have always
wanted like this is exactly what I
pictured if I were to ever make an Xbox
for myself like this is what I would
want so I'm hoping it's somebody else
out there once this as well see that
this looks like my eyes twitching
because I'm so excited
do you see what I see guys this is it
this is my Xbox that I made with my very
own two hands in a computer and a mouse
and illustrator it's so perfect
what on the auction site has a signature
on it this one does not they made two of
them so there's basically only two of
these in existence right now this one in
my hands and the one that is on the
charity site you guys want to check it
out
feel free to do so check out my console
check out everyone else's I just wanted
to make this video super quick because
this is something that I love I love
being able to help and give back and
this opportunity was just really really
awesome
a huge thank you to xbox for giving me
this opportunity and also partnering
with console for kids for making this
whole entire thing possible I think it's
really great to see companies and brands
and people just get together and try to
raise money for good causes so this is
it this is the ammo xbox that I've
always wanted again the link is in the
description if you wanna check it out
and that's it what do you guys think do
you like it because I love it
[Music]